if you're into watching people burn have
I got the episode for you it's our burn
book to be cut out girls pictures from
the yearbook and then we wrote comments
House of the Dragon episode 6 has just
released with more new faces that'll
have you going remind you who that is
again in this video we take a deep dive
into the episode the lore and
connections to Game of Thrones but don't
worry there are no book spoilers beyond
episode 6. so sit down with some roasted
goat and make sure to hit that like And
subscribe button because here we go I
hope you didn't skip the intro credits
this episode because just like Game of
Thrones would often change their
openings so too has House of the Dragon
now at first glance it looks like the
same old intro however roughly 50
seconds into it things start to change
drastically this is to reflect just how
much things have shaken up since we
first saw this family tree type intro in
episode 2. I'm gonna show you side by
side what these changes are and I'll be
flipping through the two a lot but I'll
leave text below so you know if I'm
looking at the episode 6 new version or
the episode two to five and if you want
a better understanding of just the
original version check out my episode 2
breakdown the original had these blue
emblems depicting house Valerian however
in the new version we have the opposite
side of the model showing us green for
house Hightower it's tough to see
because the background is blurred but
you can make out four distinct Trails of
blood from this emblem here this is
Alison Hightower and each trail of blood
signifies one of her four children in
the episode two to five version you'll
only see two Trails of blood since her
two other kids have not been born yet
moving forward the original showed us
viserys and his wife Emma but the new
one has Damon as identified by the
helmet he wore during the tournament in
episode 1. you'll see three Trails of
blood here one for his first wife rare
Royce one for his new wife Lena Valerian
and one that will split off into his
twin daughters Vela and Reina we get a
better view of this when we see Lena's
sigil which leads down to two identical
dragon eggs each rep presenting one of
her daughters both versions show us
rhaenyra symbolized by the Valerian
necklace she was given by Damon however
in the new version we followed the blood
to her three children with husband Lenor
Valerian in fact you can briefly see
laner's emblem off to the side here of
course it becomes a highly contentious
rumor that these three children are not
lenors but in fact Harwin strongs both
versions also have a depiction of the
soon to come dance of dragons but I'll
get to that in my spoilers video the
episode begins with the soothing sounds
of childbirth with a roughly 10 year
older raniera Targaryen played Now by
Emma Darcy she's giving birth to her
third son Joffrey yeah Lenor who has
just been pretty much drinking and
hanging out with the boys my wife
wouldn't mind me hanging out with the
boys decides to name their third child
after the titular Knight of kisses so I
guess they can officially call their
baby the Knight of pisses oh God that's
terrible rhaenyra now having three
children is a stark contrast to the
young girl who defiantly told her mother
she never wants to have children and
would rather be a brave knight of note
is the three minute long continuous shot
that doesn't break until the arrival of
older Lenor I haven't seen anyone this
excited to see a bastard since Jon Snow
arose from the dead now Queen Allison
still not over ranier's Grand betrayal
in which he lied on her mother's memory
that her maidenhood was unsullied holds
a grudge larger than casterly Rock she
immediately demands the baby be brought
to her I would like to see the baby or
likely to see if it has any of its
father's physical traits her two other
children jakaris AKA Jace and luceris
AKA Luke all have brown hair and lighter
skin tone with many in the court
believing Lenor not to be the father
that honor Belongs To Sir Harwin strong
the hand son who coincidentally saved
Rainier from getting trampled at her
welcome wedding brawl and the Queen's
command happens before the umbilical
cord has even been cut renera ever
defined makes a show of force by
physically carrying the baby mere
minutes after giving birth all the way
to the Queen's Chambers we'll later see
the trail of blood it caused by this
walk on their way to the queen Rainier
and Lena are congratulated by Lord and
Lady Caswell whose house is located in
bitter Bridge each Lord and Lady of the
realm have preferences on who should
rule should Rainier's Ascension be
questioned and Lord and Lady Caswell at
least in this interaction are making it
very public their support for rhaenyra
sir Kristen who has seemingly been let
off from murdering Joffrey and ruining
renira's wedding is the night of being a
bitter [ __ ] still holding a grudge
against her former lover he's like that
guy you meet on Tinder who sweet talks
you for weeks then as soon as you say
you're not interested calls you a [ __ ]
this is another three-minute tracking
shot with no Cuts I wonder if the
director is trying to hammer home the
fact that we don't get to rest just like
renera the camera and our Gaze on her
now of course the queen is like oh my
God what are you doing here you should
be resting I haven't seen catiness like
this since desperate Castle maidens
viserys comes limping in looking like me
after a bender of Quaaludes and Benadryl
he's completely lost his arm and most of
his hair to this mysterious affliction
action and viserys really be like that
dude from Monty Python
I'm not immediately can tell the child
is not lenors whoever the king is
blinded to this fact the episode is
filled with allusions to blindness like
when Allison's daughter Helena talks of
the millipede having eyes but being
unable to see the king sees the child
but is unable to accept that it is not
lanor's for that would mean ruin and
possibly even death for Lenor renera and
their three children it hasn't as really
stepped up her [ __ ] game
trying Selena
soon I'll let you make it what it looks
like you you did not just say that it
appears the agreement between Ranier and
Lena are about seeing other people is
still in effect however while Lena is
out partying and drinking rhaenyra is
having children something that
undoubtedly has caused a bit of
resentment being born a woman is
terribly unfair a theme that has been
prevalent throughout the season eager to
meet the new child is Sir Harwin strong
the true father he's commander of the
city watch a post once held by Damon
meanwhile Jason Luke have picked out an
egg to be cradled alongside Joffrey as
is the Targaryen tradition later in the
episode we'll learn from Lena Valerian
that not all of these eggs hatch one of
her twin daughter's eggs hatched and the
other did not the same is true with
aemond who has yet to find any dragon to
bond with but just because your egg
doesn't hatch doesn't mean you're left
without a dragon you can always claim
and bond with one should the occasion
arise for example Lena didn't bond with
vegar until she was 15. she always had
an affinity for this specific Dragon
even asking King viserys in episode 2
you where he thought this once elusive
Dragon was hiding speaking of Dragons
It's Time to get our first glimpse of
the interior of the Dragon pit in
episode 1 raenyra landed her Dragon here
but now we get to look inside for those
of you familiar with Game of Thrones
you'll see what's to become of this
giant structure roughly 170 years in the
future along with Jason Luke are Allison
and viserys Kids aegon II and aymond
technically aegon and amond are both
Jace and Luke's uncles we witnessed
Jason his bonding lesson with his Dragon
Vermax it looks like the dragon Tamer
dude has had his fair share of scuffles
with some of these creatures it's
essential that Jace fully bonds with
this Dragon once that happens the dragon
will refuse instruction from any other
and were treated to a delicious roasted
goat aegon II or as I like to call him
Finn wolfhard is actually David
Tennant's son he's definitely got that
fire of the Dragon within him teasing
his nephews and especially his brother
aemond they even get him his own dragon
pink dread and the great thing about him
is if you can't ride him you can at
least eat them also check out the green
tunics here for Allison's boys we'll see
a lot of green here especially in
Allison's dresses now eamond really
wants a dragon even venturing deeper
into the dragon pit and stumbling upon
this guy apparently this isn't the first
time aemond has nearly been burnt to
death exploring the dragon pit
unaccompanied something he'll later be
chastised for by his mother and we also
get our first glimpse of Helena who we
last Saw as a baby in episode 4. and is
it just me or did any of you feel
something was a little off with her and
I don't just mean her obsession with
bugs Allison is quick to blame Jason
Luke for teasing Eamonn failing to
acknowledge that it's her own son
leading the charge in an episode where
there's a lot of talk about parents
being blind to things Allison is just as
guilty in fact it's only Lars who later
says in voiceover near the end of the
episode that children are nothing but a
liability it also looks like viserys's
model Valerian City continues to grow as
we've seen it ever expanding since
episode 1. The King basically tells Al
listen to can it about these rumors
concerning his grandchildren's parentage
using the excuse that her dragons would
never have hatched if they had been
bastards he's also like oh yeah I once
saw this horse bang another horse and it
came out a different color it's science
sir Kristen calls renira a spider who
stings and sucks her prey dry I guess
he'd have first-hand knowledge of her
sucking ability but Allison doesn't like
his tone even though she hates renera
she needs to believe that honor and
decency will prevail if she really
believes that she won't last long
playing The Game of Thrones speaking of
decency her son is knocking it to the
wind I'd hate to be the guy below that
windowsill and honestly aegon is this
super naive self-absorbed teen who
doesn't really understand what's going
on around him when his mother tells him
Jace will be king one day he's like sure
I don't care just let me get back to
wooing Young maidens in this way aegon
is kind of like his mom when she was
young not fully understanding the
reality of things around him echoing
Auto speech from last episode Allison
tells her son that when raniera takes
the throne she she could have her and
her children killed to strengthen her
claim to the throne even if aegon
himself doesn't challenge it simply by
living He poses a challenge across the
narrow sea at pentos Damon and Lena show
off their dragons to its people they are
the honored guests of Prince Reggio who
will later ask they join his city as
their honored guest to be bestowed
tributes in anything they should desire
in exchange for protection lease in the
triarchy the same group that invaded the
stepsons have made an alliance with corn
Martell of Dorne which puts pentos on
The Chopping Block so to have three
dragons protecting them would be a
tremendous asset in the book Damon and
Lena travel to pentos after their
wedding knowing viserys would not be too
pleased with their engagement it's there
that Lena has her twin daughters Bella
and Reina but the way the show plays out
Bella and Reina are already born Damon
seems to enjoy one daughter far more
than the other teaching her High
Valerian while the other one sits alone
with the dragon egg that's never hatched
we learn from Lena that Damon has an
obsession with the Dragon Riders of old
so he may think his one daughter who
hasn't tamed one to be undeserving of
his time father of the year reggio's
gracious offer is something Damon highly
considers but his wife steers him away
saying both he and the children deserve
more she also makes an ominous statement
that she doesn't want to die living a
boring country life but rather a dragon
Rider's death in the courtyard the boys
are trained by Sir Kristen Cole all of
them having about as much skill as me
trying to unicycle on Ice according to
Harwin who I guess is Milling around his
own kids under the guise of being on the
city watch sir Kristen is spending more
time on Allison's kids than rhaenyra's
thus Cole suggests the two eldest boys
duke it out it's basically another way
Kristen can get back at his former lover
watching them is Lionel strong still
hand of the king and viserys who seems
to have gotten a hold of some Hooch when
Kristen makes a snide remark about
Harwin being Jason Luke's father Harwin
snaps and Joffrey's him in the face
taking four men to hold him back when
Rainier is informed of this incident she
uses the secret doorway Damon told her
about in episode 4 but Eaves drops on a
conversation between Harwin and his
father this show has a hell of a lot of
eavesdropping from demon on the small
Council in episode 1 to Allison
overhearing about the infamous coupling
anyway she hears Lionel chewing out
Harwin over this Outburst which is only
going to add fuel to the rumors that he
is Jason Luke's baby daddy and if rodira
doesn't have enough [ __ ] to deal with
her drunk husband comes home with a new
boy toy sir Carl Corey apparently he
showed him a sack of sapphires he slew
from a pirate but knowing sir laner
that's not the only sack he was shown
laner wants to go back to the Sea he
yearns for adventure he even talks of a
tairoshi general who dyed his hair
purple and wears women's clothing this
is a reference to recalio rendoon who in
the book is kind of the guy who takes
over the Cherokee Invasion after crab
feeder's defeat now that the triarchy
has allied with Dorne their presence in
the stepsons is something the kingdom
should not take lightly Rainier commands
her husband to stay now of all moments
they need to show themselves ourselves
as a strong family get it Harwin strong
anyways later makes this metaphor that
the wise sailor flees the storm as it
gathers but raniera says you can't
abandon your post when this storm comes
this is a complete contradiction to what
Corliss said in episode 2 that you must
never wait for an oncoming storm these
metaphors are also great hints at how
people like Rainier would rule should
she become Queen Lena attempts to cheer
up that one daughter Damon doesn't seem
to care about telling her that one day
she will be a rider in her daughter's
mind if she had a dragon maybe that
could earn her her father's love maybe
if I finally become a lawyer I'll earn
my father's love the small council
convenes with another Petty squabble
between the black woods and brackens in
episode 4 while Ranier was on her
Whirlwind tour of romance you may recall
Willem Blackwood slaying Gerald Bracken
the feud between these two houses has
been going on for centuries and still
seems to be going strong rhaenyra the
future Heir and Allison are both a part
of this Council something that's not in
the book taking over our expert tea
maker Melos who passed away peacefully
between episodes 5 and 6 is our new
grand maester urwil you may recall
suggesting a poultice to heal the king
rather than leeches maybe that's what we
can attribute to viserys living so long
once Mellows passed or while was able to
use his experimental medicine that the
old Master shied away from Lord
beastberry master of coin is still here
but he can't even keep up with the
conversation and to his left is Thailand
Lannister master of ships the last new
face here is who I believe is Jasper
Wilde master of laws however he only
really has about one or two lines in the
whole episode one of the things I've
really been enjoying about this show is
how have you been able to subtly
introduce some of these characters who
may go on to play larger roles in the
future as my dad likes to say arguments
are never what they're about and this is
totally what's at play here when Rainier
and Allison argue about the step Stones
renyra believes they should have built
garrisons and sent men there while
Alison is more pragmatic money just
doesn't grow on trees to do this Allison
is worried about the cost to its
citizens while Rainier believed there's
no cost too high when it comes to war
the show is really painting a picture of
how Rainier will rule if she's in charge
notice also that Rainier's ball here is
black and Allison's is green Rainier is
no stranger to playing the Game of
Thrones she has to make a drastic move
to take the heat off the rumors
regarding the parentage of her children
thus she proposes in front of the entire
small Council that her eldest son Jace
be married to Allison's daughter Helena
this would strengthen both houses and
viserys is like that is so sweet and I'm
like it's a bold strategy cotton let's
see if it pays off for him in addition
renira sweetens the deal by offering
Eamonn his choice of egg should Cyrax
have another clutch but like any great
meeting it's interrupted by lactation
don't tell homelander Allison has no
intention of considering this proposal
even though viserys thinks it'll make
the family stronger she could sense the
desperation in Rainier's voice and
believes it's only a matter of time
until her secret comes out especially
when Lionel comes to resign although
Harwin has been expelled from the City
watch Lionel believes the punishment
should go further that he himself
resigned as hand of the king for a quote
Shadow looming over his house and what
it seems he's about to Spill the Beans
about rhaenyra's children Allison just
watches on like say something damn it
but Lionel can't do it thus viserys does
not allow him to resign although the
king allows him to escort his son to
their house seat at harrenhal the same
place the great Council was held in
episode 1. as Allison makes her way back
to her Chambers take a look at this maid
scurrying away there's no evidence to
support this but I'd like to think she's
coming back from talking to Loris I
imagine Lara says several people in the
castle collecting Vital Information
which he can then weaponize it seems as
though his alliance with the princess
has grown since we last saw the two talk
in the gardens almost a decade ago and
judging by the way he speaks about his
brother and father he doesn't really
care about them he flat out tells the
queen that it's true Harwin is the
father of raniera's children and even
orchestrates his father and brother's
death now he says he did this for the
queen but considering harrenhal will now
fall under lars's control it's hard not
to think he had ulterior motives in the
book The Fire is considered an accident
and there's even a suggestion that the
fire was started by Damon who wanted to
kill Harwin so as to remove one of her
lovers there's another rumor that it was
Corliss for Harwin having slept with his
son's wife but the show depicts a far
more nefarious plot in which Lara sets
some death row inmates free in exchange
for burning harrenhal down with Harwin
and Lionel in it he even has the
perpetrator's tongues cut out just in
case now I'm curious what this Beetle
symbol on lars's Cane is since there's
no mention of this in the book the same
symbol can be found on the pin he gives
to his assassins and beetles can also be
found in Helena's insect collection I'll
be keeping my eye on this Meanwhile Back
On pentos Lena attempts to give birth
and Damon is confronted with a dilemma
very similar to viserys's in episode 1.
do they cut the baby out and risk
killing the mother but Lena musters her
strength to visit Vega R in the book she
wanted to ride her one last time before
her death but collapses before reaching
her in the show she does end up making
it to her and commands her to be burned
she did say she wanted a dragon Rider's
death after all Harwin says goodbye to
his boys and Promises to come back so
that was a [ __ ] lie deep down Jace
knows this is his father and when he
confronts his mother about it she merely
States he's a Targaryen and that's all
that matters lane or spars with Carl
just like he used to do with Joffrey
Rainier comes to tell him there to
venture to Dragonstone away from these
vicious rumors she would have preferred
to stay at King's Landing to prevent
Allison from manipulating her father but
the heat is too much at least Lenor gets
to bring his boy along we get a brief
scene of the king looking at his first
wife Emma's ring it's clear after all
these years he still thinks of her
skulking Abode is a mouse or a rat I
always get those two mixed up and
they've been nothing but ill Omens
throughout the series we saw one the
night rhaenyra went out on the town and
one among Joffrey's blood the night of
the wedding thing if this is any
indication viserys is not long for this
world but knowing this guy he'll last
another five seasons
Loris essentially goes full mask off
telling the queen he played some part in
the fire which killed his brother and
father and he did it on her behalf after
all when the queen makes a wish who
would struggle not to fulfill it and if
that wasn't creepy enough he tells her
that one day she will reward him when
the time is right Laura says definitely
earned five Peter baelish's out of five
now if you want to find out what we can
expect next episode I usually have a
full preview breakdown video within 24
hours of this one so make sure you're
subscribed for that thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like And subscribe
and leave me your comments and theories
below as always you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
foreign